this is a Fox News Alert and a very
strange story The Pentagon as you may
have heard is Now tracking a very high
altitude Chinese spy balloon over the
northern United States apparently it's
over Montana right now they're seeing
photographs of that balloon on your
screen the Pentagon has decided for some
reason not to shoot down the balloon
even though they say it's flying over
some quote sensitive sites
so they're intercontinental ballistic
missile silos in that area what is this
trying to establish Jamil Jaffer from
the National Security Institute um
thanks so much for coming on this you
know presents make a lot of complicated
decisions this doesn't seem complicated
there's a Chinese Bible and why not
shoot it down what do you think is
happening here yeah it's a great
question Tucker you know what's really
interesting about this incident is that
the defense department has made clear
that this isn't the first time that
we've seen Chinese spy balloons over U.S
territory in the past what's interesting
about this particular incident is the
fact that we've called it out we've made
it public and that they actually froze
the airspace over Billings Montana and
put planes up thinking about taking the
shot now why they didn't take the shot
why they didn't take it down hard to
know Tucker but it's worth noting back
in 2001 the Chinese forced down an
American spy plane on Hainan island
kidnapped U.S Airmen air women for a
number of days and stole a bunch of
surveillance assets off that plane now
that was almost two decades ago
so you you almost answer my question do
you think if the the American Pentagon
floated a spy balloon over Chinese
missile bases that chairman G would say
you know I'm just I'm not really sure
how to respond maybe we should just let
it keep floating yeah look I think
that's highly unlikely I mean you saw
Nancy Pelosi went to Taiwan uh just a
few months back and Kevin McCarthy is
going to uh Taiwan shortly and the
Chinese were threatening to shoot down
Nancy Pelosi's playing so you know it's
clear that the Chinese would take action
it's surprising that we're not
I you know you want to be as Fair as you
can in situations like this because
there's so much we don't know but and
you're tempted to LEAP the conclusion
these people are completely impotent but
it could there be a good reason I'm not
shooting it down well you know you could
say that they wanted to see where it's
going to go what it's trying to track is
it looking at our icbms is it looking at
something else they may be collecting
information off of it too so there's a
possibility there are good reasons for
not shooting it down but it is odd that
you would announce it make it clear that
you've seen it and then not take action
well that's exactly right it's such a
smart observation I appreciate it thank
you so much thanks Tucker subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube channel to catch
our nightly opens stories that are
changing the world and changing your
life from Tucker Carlson tonight